[Musik]
von allen Regierungen der Welt gibt es
eine die die Geschehnisse in der Ukraine
mit besonderer Aufmerksamkeit verfolgt
jede Minute jeden Tag und diese
Regierung ist keine andere als die
Taiwans denn sie regiert eine Insel die
alle Voraussetzungen dafür zu erfüllen
scheint der nächste Protagonist einer
großen internationalen Krise zu werden
seit mehr als 70 Jahren lebt Taiwan
unter dem Schutz der USA am Rande des
chinesischen Regimes aber immer mit der
latenten Gefahr das Peking eines Tages
versuchen könnte die Insel zu erobern
natürlich könnte diese Hypothese diese
Möglichkeit einen Konflikt Auslösen der
weit über die bewaffnete
Auseinandersetzung auf regionaler Ebene
hinausgehen würde es wäre das erste Mal
seit dem Vietnamkrieg dass sich die USA
und China in einem Einsatzgebiet
gegenüberstehen könnten zumindest ist
das der übliche Eindruck den man bekommt
wenn auch nur durch aussagen wie
[Musik]
diese
und die Frage ist was passieren könnte
wenn der Konflikt in Taiwan schließlich
ausbricht würde es China gelingen die
Kontrolle über die Insel zu übernehmen
in diesem Video werden wir diese Fragen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
beantworten wir haben es schon oft
erwähnt die Situation Taiwans ist in der
internationalen Politik eine der
zweideutigsten vor allem weil die
Souveränität dieser Insel ständigen
Veränderungen unterworfen ist z.B und
das mag euch überraschen hatat das
kingreich nach dem Ende des
chinesisch-japanischen Krieges 1895 die
Insel für immer an Japan ab das heißt
dass die Insel Formosa Taiwan formell
nicht mehr zu China gehörte und so
gehörte die Insel die nächsten 50 Jahre
zum japanischen Kaiserreich natürlich
brachte die Niederlage Tokos im Zweiten
Weltkrieg wieder eine Wende die Insel
wurde wieder Teil der damaligen Republik
China einem Land das von einer
Militärdiktatur regiert wurde und in
gewisser WE mit den Vereinigten Staaten
verbündet war doch als die Revolution
von Mao zon 1949 erfolgreich war wurde
das autoritäre Regime der Republik China
nach Taiwan verbandt seitdem wird die
Insel von Peking als eine Art
rebellische Provinz betrachtet eine
Insel die völlig autonom ist und in der
Praxis wie ein souveränes Land
funktioniert die aber nie in der Lage
war ihre Unabhängigkeit zu
erklären erstens weil ihre Regierung
sich als rechtmäßige Regierung Chinas
betrachtete und zweitens weil immer
wieder betonte dass jede
Unabhängigkeitserklärung als
Kriegshandlung angesehen würde und so
wurde es zu einem Land geformt das in
den letzten Jahrzehnten einen
bedeutenden wirtschaftlichen
technologischen und auch demokratischen
Erfolg erlebt hat in politischer und
sozialer Hinsicht ist Taiwan zum
freisten Gebiet auf dem gesamten
asiatischen Kontinent geworden das
Problem ist aber Chinas Appetit wird
größer und größer und wenn uns der Krieg
in der Ukraine etwas gezeigt hat dann
dass die Gebietsansprüche der großen
Mächte wieder einmal ein mögliches
Szenario für einen militärischen
Konflikt sind die Frage ist daher wird
Taiwan die neue Ukraine wie würde eine
chinesische Invasion auf der Insel
Aussehen wer wäre daran beteiligt und
was wären die möglichen Folgen genau das
werden wir jetzt unter die Lupe nehmen
zuvor muss ich jedoch eine Entdeckung
mit euch teilen vielleicht interessiert
es euch ja zu sehen wo ich eigentlich so
meine videoskripte schreibe nun wenn das
Wetter es erlaubt setze ich mich
meistens in den Garten an mein a4i
Tablet und haue dann in die Tasten
vorher muss ich mich jedoch ausgiebig
informieren aus dem Web aus Studien und
natürlich aus der und dabei bin ich auf
eine App gestoßen die sowohl auf meinem
Handy als auch Tablet und PC läuft und
mein Leseerlebnis geradezu
revolutioniert hat reedley readedley ist
Deutschlands führender digitaler Kiosk
und die App für alle deine
lieblingsmagazine und Zeitungen
readedley schafft die bequemst und
intuitivste Form des digitalen Lesens
ganz einfach und unbegrenzt in einer App
es bietet eine Unmenge an
deutschsprachigen und internationalen
Lieblingstiteln die jederzeit nur einen
Klick entfernt sind ohne dass ich Zick
Abos bei verschiedenen Verlagen
abschließen muss RLE ermöglicht es mir
auf über 7000 Zeitschriften und
Millionen Artikel zuzugreifen und das
beste man kann sein Konto mit bis zu
fünf anderen Menschen teilen das macht
Rele zur perfekten Lösung für die
gesamte Familie der Hammer im Dezember
gibt es als Weihnachtsangebot einen
ganzen Monat für nur 99 Cent danach
beträgt der Preis 14,99 € pro Monat man
kann das Abo aber jederzeit kündigen
wichtig dieses super Angebot kannst du
nur über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung und nur für begrenzte
zeitnutzen also lass es dir nicht
entgehen so und jetzt fragst du dich
aber sicher welchen Content dir readedle
eigentlich bietet nun ich habe mich dies
auch gefragt und war dann komplett Buff
von renommierten Qualitätszeitungen wie
z.B der necher Zeitung einer der letzten
Bastion des deutschsprachigen Liberalen
Journalismus dem Guardian dem
independent der Welt und unglaublich
vielen anderen über unzählige
wissenschaftsratgeber Finanz und
hobbymagazine bis hin zu Comics das rent
wird auch ständig erweitert kürzlich ist
z.B gelor t3n Focus Focus m bunte und
vieles mehr hinzugekommen mich hat auch
beeindruckt dass wirklich aus allen
Ecken des politischen Spektrums was
dabei ist ob links Mitte oder rechts so
kann man dann auch mal außerhalb seiner
Bubble stöbern was ja besonders wertvoll
für die Erweiterung des eigenen
meinungshorizonts ist in diesem riesigen
Repertoir findest garantiert auch du
sowohl deine lieblingsmedien als auch
jene die du hast aber genau diese
Mischung macht doch am meisten Spaß und
bereitet unendliches Lesevergnügen
natürlich gibt es eine offline
Lesefunktion mit der man seine
Lieblingsartikel auch überall unterwegs
genießen kann auch wenn man gerade kein
Internet hat und überlegt mal digitales
Lesen von Magazin und Zeitung spart
Tonnen an CO2 und Müll RLE hat
ausgerechnet dass es 16600 Tonn CO2
einspart was etwa dem jährlichen Ausstoß
von 7000 PKW entspricht nicht schlecht
oder also tauche ein in die unendliche
Vielfalt der Magazine und Zeitungen bei
reedley Klick jetzt gleich auf den Link
in der Videobeschreibung um das
Sonderangebot im Dezember zu erhalten
ein Monat für nur 99 Cent wie gesagt es
ist unverbindlich und jederzeit kündtbar
ich bin überzeugt dass du dein neues
Leseerlebnis genießen
wirst zwei
Ausgangspunkte das erste was du beachten
solltest ist dass bei der Hypothese
eines Krieges zwischen den USA und China
in Taiwan beide Seiten eine völlig
unterschiedliche Sicht der Dinge haben
daraus ergeben sich einige wichtige
Punkte die wir im Auge behalten
[Musik]
sollten für Peking ist die Taiwan Frage
eine rein innenpolitische Angelegenheit
da die Insel zur Republik China gehörte
und die maor Revolution diese durch das
aktuelle Kommunist Regime die
Volksrepublik China ersetzt hat ist
Taiwan aus ihrer Sicht eine chinesische
Provinz mit einem de facto besonderen
Maß an Autonomie mit anderen Worten die
Regierung von shishinping ist der
Ansicht dass eine Militäroperation kein
Zusammenstoß zwischen Ländern wäre
sondern ein Ereignis dass die innere
territoriale Ordnung Chinas betrifft und
bedenk bitte dass diese Position Pekings
die wachsende Feindseligkeit gegenüber
jeder ausländischen Gruppe erklärt die
sich auf der Insel einmischt sie sehen
es als eine Art Demütigung an ein Gefühl
das durch die jahrelange kommunistische
Propaganda noch verstärkt wurde 9
Oktober 2021 China Ski verspricht die
Wiedervereinigung mit Taiwan die USA
halten jedoch ihrerseits eine
Verpflichtung gegenüber Taiwan aufrecht
die mit dieser Position nicht ganz
vereinbar ist im Taiwan relations Act
vom 10 April 1979 haben sich die
Vereinigten Staaten uneingeschränkt zu
diesem Gebiet bekannt die Vereinigten
Staaten Stellen Taiwan
verteidigungsgüter und
verteidigungsdienstleistung in dem
Umfang zur Verfügung der erforderlich
ist um Taiwan in die Lage zu versetzen
aus reichende Fähigkeiten zur
Selbstverteidigung aufrecht zuerhalten
Abschnitt 3 des Taiwan relations Act mit
anderen Worten das Gesetz macht es
deutlich Taiwan muss in der Lage sein
sich gegen jeden Versuch eine Aggression
zu verteidigen und die US OFA werden zu
ihrer Verantwortung stehen sollte diese
Situation eintreten tatsächlich scheint
es nicht viel Sinn zu machen über
Taiwans Verteidigung zu sprechen außer
mit den USA und warum nun seht euch mal
das folgende
an David versus
Goliat die erste Frage die wir
beantworten müssen lautet wenn sich
China dazu entschließt in Taiwan
einzumarschieren welche Länder wären
dann an diesem Konflikt beteiligt und
hier kommt der wichtigste Punkt der
us-dipomatie ins Spiel strategische
Zweideutigkeit seit Jahren hat
Washington zumindest offiziell nie
klargestellt ob es in diesem möglichen
Konflikt eingreifen würde oder nicht und
das hat es nicht getan um eine doppelte
Abschreckung zu schaffen einerseits
könnte die latente Bedrohung durch ein
Eingreifen der USA China davon abhalten
sich für eine invas der Insel zu
entscheiden andererseits verhindert
diese Ungewissheit auch dass taipe
übermäßig aggressiv vorgeht indem es z.B
seine Unabhängigkeit erklärt das ist der
Ansatz der nach Meinung viele Analysten
den Frieden über Jahrzehnte erhalten hat
die Dinge entwickeln sich jedoch weiter
das chinesische Militär ist immer besser
gerüstet und wenn der Krieg in der
Ukraine etwas deutlich gemacht hat dann
dass die Strategie der strategischen
Zweideutigkeit am Ende shijinpings
vorwahn sein könnte um sich auf seine
Beute zu stürzen das heißt wenn
hochrangige chinesische Beamte zu einem
bestimmten Zeitpunkt Meinung sind dass
die Vereinigten Staaten Taiwan nicht zu
Hilfe kommen und sich z.B mit der
Verhängung von Sanktionen zufrieden
geben könnten das könnte deine beste
Auslöser für eine Invasion sein es wäre
dann ähnlich wie bei der russischen
Invasion in der Ukraine Putin und sein
Gefolge hatten das Gefühl dass wenn es
hart auf hart kommt niemand einen Finger
für Kiev rühren würde und das erklärt
warum Joe Biden sich absichtlich nicht
einmal nicht zweimal sondern gleich
dreimal versprochen hat indem er
klarstellte dass die Vereinigten Staaten
ihren Verbündeten zu Hilfe kommen
US forces US wom taiw inent chese invion
yes I don't want to war ch just want
make China understand that we are not
step back we are not
anying United States would come to
Taiwan Def ch att yes we have a
commitment are
willingw
mit anderen Worten Washington hat seine
formale Position nicht geändert aber der
Präsident wollte die Position des Weißen
Hauses deutlich machen vielleicht hat es
viel damit zu tun dass die
fortschrittliche Halbleiterindustrie
Taiwan zu einer absolut strategischen
Enklave für die Vereinigten Staaten
gemacht hat amerikanische Konzerne
amerikanische Technologie und egal ob
wir über künstliche Intelligenz Amazon
oder die F35 sprechen sie alle brauchen
Chips von TSMC und ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass das die Entschlossenheit der
USA weiter unterstützt aber warum ist
die Position der amerikanischen macht
überhaupt so wichtig nun im Grunde weil
die amerikanische macht taip einziger
Trumpf ist und warum nun seht's euch
[Musik]
an das Kräfteverhältnis zwischen Taiwan
und der Volksrepublik China hat sich im
Laufe der Zeit immer weiter
verschlechtert wenn die chinesischen
Streitkräfte traditionell eine schlecht
ausgerüstete schlecht ausgebildete und
eher unfähige Armee waren sieht die
Situation heute ganz anders aus die
Volksrepublik China unternimmt enorme
Anstrengungen um ihre militärischen
Fähigkeiten zu verbessern dazu gehören
sechs neue Flugzeugträger Kampfflugzeuge
der fünften Generation neue amphibische
Fähigkeiten und Abertausende von Raketen
die auf Taiwan gerichtet sind ja es
stimmt dass Taiwan seine Militärausgaben
auf den Schutz eines viel kleineren
Gebiets konzentriert 36 000 quadrkm im
Vergleich zu mehr als 9 Millionen aber
China richtet den Großteil seiner
Militärausgaben auf die maritime
Vorherrschaft in der Region
einschließlich der Fähigkeit in Taiwan
einzufallen tatsächlich könnte die
wachsende Kluft zwischen den
Streitkräften der Grund dafür sein dass
Taiwan seine militärischen Anstrengungen
in den letzten Jahren reduziert hat die
Vorstellung dass ein weltoffenes China
jede Gefahr einer Invasion ausschließen
könnte und das letztendlich alles von
der Position der USA abhängt erklärt
vielleicht Diagramme wie
dieses das könnte sich jetzt ändern aber
die Wahrheit ist dass es Taiwan ohne
internationale Unterstützung sehr schwer
fallen würde eine Invasion Chinas
standzuhalten 17 Juni 2022 China stellt
den modernsten Flugzeugträger der Welt
außerhalb der USA in Dienst mit seinem
neuen Flugzeugträger vom Typ 003 holt
China zu einem neuen militärischen
Schlag aus 15 April 2023 durchgesierte
Dokumente zeigen dass Taiwan sehr
anfällig für chinesische Luftangriffe
ist beunruhigende Details werfen Fragen
über die Fähigkeit der US-Geheimdienste
auf eine bevorstehende Invasion zu
erkennen und die Fähigkeit der Insel
sich selbst zu verteidigen nehmen wir
nun an dass aus irgendeinem Grund
schließlich alles schiefläuft die Dinge
außer Kontrolle geraten und der Konflikt
explodiert was könnte dann passieren wie
sehe das Kräfteverhältnis aus würde sich
einer der Kontrahenten klar durchsetzen
nun schauen wir uns das mal lieber
an
[Musik]
Kriegsspiele was könnte passieren wenn
in Taiwan tatsächlich ein Krieg
ausbricht diese Hypothese ist gar nicht
so weit hergeholt und wird daher in
Washington sehr sehr ernst genommen
genau aus diesem Grund haben mehrere
US-amerikanische Forschungs und
verteidigungszentren Simulationen durch
geführt um herauszufinden wie sich
dieser mögliche Konflikt entwickeln
würde in fast allen Fällen wird davon
ausgegangen dass die usstitkräfte
teilnehmen würden da sonst Taiwans
Niederlage sicher wäre nehmen wir z.B
die Simulation des Center for strategic
and international studies einer
führenden Denkfabrik mitsit in
Washington als Ausgangspunkt um diese
Simulation durchzuführen wurden alle
möglichen Luft und Marineoperationen
berücksichtigt sowie alle historischen
präsidenzfälle mit amphibischen
Einsätzen von der Normandie über okinava
bis zu den forlandineln die Ergebnisse
nun seht sie euch an in den meisten
szenar würde es den USA Taiwan und Japan
gelingen Chinas konventionelle
amphibische Invasion abzuwehren und
Taiwans Autonomie zu erhalten diese
Verteidigung wäre jedoch mit einem hohen
Preis verbunden die USA und ihre
Verbündeten würden Dutzende von Schiffen
und hunderte von Flugzeugen verlieren
und tausende von Opfern erleiden stellt
euch vor die USA müssten Tausende von
Meilen entfernt gegen ein chinesisches
Militär kämpfen das auf heimischem Boden
spielt Taiwans Wirtschaft würde durch
die Zerstörung eines Großteils der
Infrastruktur am Boden liegen natürlich
würde auch China große Verluste erleiden
und das scheitnd der Operation könnte
die Regierung der Kommunistischen Partei
Chinas destabilisieren die Ergebnisse
dieser Simulation zeigen dass es China
nur dann gelingen würde die Kontrolle
über die Insel zu übernehmen wenn Taiwan
allein gelassen
[Musik]
wird doch selbst in diesem Szenario
könnte der taiwanesische Widerstand die
Invasion um 70 Tage verlängern okay ich
weiß jetzt was einige von euch denken da
sind sie wieder die Jungs von
visualpolitik die Propaganda für die
imperialistische Vorherrschaft von ankel
SEM machen nun das tun wir weder jetzt
noch haben wir es jemals zu vor getan
denn tatsächlich sind all diese
Überlegungen und Simulationen alles
andere als ermutigend für die
Vereinigten Staaten in der Simulation
bedeutet selbst das beste Szenario
extrem hohe Verluste für die USA und
Japan sowie extrem fatale
wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen mit anderen
Worten egal wie es ausgeht niemand würde
gewinnen jeder chinesische Versuch in
Taiwan einzumarschieren wäre eine
Katastrophe für alle Beteiligten aber
das ist noch nicht
alles die Ergebnisse dieser Simulation
warnen von mehr als drei weiteren
möglichen Risiken erstens könnten die
durch Cyberangriffe verursachten Schäden
erhebliche wirtschaftliche und soziale
Schäden in den Vereinigten Staaten
selbst verursachen zweitens könnte der
Schaden den die US-Streitkräfte erlitten
haben schwer zu ersetzen sein der
Wiederaufbau der Kapazitäten könnte
Jahre dauern während China das über eine
größere industrielle Kapazität verfügt
ein solches Szenario nutzen könnte um
den Spieß umzudrehen es würde sich in
Taiwan also um einen pyussieg für die
Vereinigten Staaten Handeln drittens
könnten Länder wie Russland Nordkorea
oder Iran diese Ablenkung und die
Erschöpfung der us-ressourcen ausnutzen
um ihre eigenen politischen Ziele
voranzutreiben mit anderen Worten selbst
wenn die USA die annextion Taiwans durch
China heute verhindern könnten wären die
potenziellen Risiken extrem
hoch denn manchmal ist es im Krieg nicht
so wichtig zu gewinnen die Geschichte
lehrt uns in dieser Hinsicht wichtige
Lektionen z.B drückte der französische
Marschall Ferdinand fosch 1919 nach der
Unterzeichnung des versill Vertrag seine
Besorgnis über den Ausgang des Ersten
Weltkriegs aus wir haben einen
20jährigen Waffenstillstand
unterzeichnet der Marschall war der
Meinung dass Frankreich trotz des
gewonnenen Krieges stark dezimiert war
und in nicht allzu fner Zukunft durch
eine deutsche Wiederaufrüstung
verwundbar sein könnte nun er hatte
Recht und die heutigen Simulation legen
nahe dass den Vereinigten Staaten etwas
ganz ähnliches passieren
[Musik]
könnte und bedenk bitte dass die Folgen
dieser Angelegenheit noch viel komplexer
werden könnten und zwar auch ohne den
Ausbruch eines Krieges wie wir ih uns
alle vorstellen im Januar 2022 führte
nämlich eine andere Denkfabrik das
Center for a new American Security eine
Simulation durch umzusehen was mit der
Halbleiterindustrie passieren könnte und
die Ergebnisse waren nicht gerade
optimistisch im Juni 2022 FHTE
dieselbeed Denkfabrik auch eine
Simulation durch wie der Krieg verlaufen
könnte in diesem Fall würde Pekin kurz
vor der Invasion vor einem großen
Dilemma stehen sie müssten sich
entscheiden ob sie sich ausschließlich
auf Taiwan konzentrieren und einen
Angriff auf die US-Streitkräfte
vermeiden in der Hoffnung dass diese
nicht eingreifen oder aber die
Amerikaner wirklich direkt anzugreifen
um sich ein militärisch Vorteil zu
verschaffen und zu versuchen eine
Verhandlung zu erzwingen das Kuriose an
dieser Simulation ist dass sich China am
Ende dafür entscheiden würde Taiwan
parallel zu eine Offensive auf nahe
gelegene US-Basen anzugreifen und wisst
ihr was es ist bekannt dass das
chinesische Militär für Angriffe auf die
usfotte trainiert wie du auf diesen
Bildern in der Wüste der Provinz
shinjang sehen kannst verwenden die
Chinesen für ihr raketentrainingziele
die Flugzeugträgern der nimitklasse und
anderen US-Kriegsschiffen nachempfunden
sind ist das ein großes
wandsignal
nun nach den Simulationen die wir hier
diskutieren wäre eine der Option Chinas
taiilwan nicht mit Raketen anzugreifen
um seine technologische Industrie nicht
erthft zu schädigen und stattdessen eine
Atombombe im Pazifik zu zünden um die
Amerikaner einzuschüchtern und
Verhandlungen zu erzwingen das würde
auch die jüngste Eile erklären mit der
shiinping den Bau weiterer Atomwaffen
voranzutreiben scheint mit anderen
Worten wenn sie wirklich gewillt sind
eine solche Drohung auszusprechen muss
sie um glaubwürdig zu sein und Wirkung
zu zeigen mit der stärkstmöglichen Kraft
untermauert werden China übertrifft die
USA bereits bei den bodengestützten
nuklearen Offensivfähigkeiten china hat
bereits mehr bodengestützte Atomraketen
als die Vereinigten Staaten obwohl es
sie bei der Gesamtzahl der
Atomsprengköpfe noch nicht überholt hat
China wird bis 2035 wahrscheinlich 1500
Atomsprengköpfe haben das Ergebnis der
meisten Simulationen ist dass die USA
China militärisch übertreffen würden
aber dass sie dafür einen zu hohen Preis
zahlen müssten weil sie nicht
ausreichend vorbereitet sind und weißt
du was an dieser Stelle macht die Arbeit
von außenmister Anthony blinken und
ungsmister ly Austin die sich für
verteidigungsabkommen in der Region
einsetzen allen Sinn der Welt es ist
möglich dass die beste und vielleicht
einzige wirksame Methode China
abzuschrecken darin besteht dass die
Vereinigten Staaten sich die
Unterstützung vieler weiterer
Konkurrenten sichern die von Japan
Südkorea Australien Großbritanniens und
so weiter und so fort mit anderen Worten
in diesem Fall ist die us-karte allein
vielleicht nicht mehr abschreckend genug
für China und das für direkt zu einer
weiteren Frage was konnten wir aus der
ukrainischen Erfahrung lernen und was
nicht
was Taiwan von der Ukraine nicht lernen
kann ein Problem bei Taiwans
Verteidigung ist dass der Versuch das zu
wiederholen was in der Ukraine getan
wurde um eine ausländische Invasion zu
verhindern möglicherweise nicht machbar
ist die geographische Situation ist
völlig anders ich denke ihr werdet die
Unterschiede auf diesen Karten gut
erkennen können im ukrainekrieg haben
sowohl die USA als auch die anderen
natoverbündeten riesige Mengen an ausr
nachschob über den Landweg geschickt was
in Taiwan aufgrund der Insellage
unmöglich wäre in diesem Fall könnte
China die Insel für Wochen oder sogar
Monate isolieren tatsächlich hat das
chinesische Militär am 8 April
mindestens drei Tage lang geprobt wie es
eine totale Einkreisung Taiwans
durchführen könnte um den Vereinigten
Staaten jede Möglichkeit zu nehmen die
lokalen selbstverteidigungskräfte zu
versorgen das ist eine Strategie die
durch Dinge wie diese hier noch
verstärkt wird 22 August 2022 die
aktuellen beschaffungs und anaufs Pläne
zeigen dass die Vereinigten Staaten in
10 Jahren nicht wesentlich mehr
Streitkräfte in der Region einsetzen
können als heute die US-Marine
modernisiert sich zwar wird aber erst im
Jahr 2045 über ihre geplante Flotte von
450 bis 500 Schiffen verfügen eine
Flottengröße die China in nur 10 Jahren
haben wird daher muss jeder Versuch
Taiwan zu verteidigen damit beginnen
dass die Insel darauf vorbereitet ist
eine Invasion jederzeit abzuwehren
einschließlich aller Munition und aller
Vorräte die zum Widerstand nötig
sind
die USA müssen ihrerseits in der Lage
sein sehr schnell Truppen und Ausrüstung
nach oder in die Nähe von Taiwan zu
verlegen und wisst ihr was all das was
wir sehen ist der Grund warum Taiwan für
Sicherheits und verteidigungsbeamte zur
Priorität Nummer 1 wird nicht nur in
ihrer eigenen Regierung sondern auch im
uskongress 20 April 2023 US Kriegsspiel
gegen Taiwan zeigt Bedarf an
entschlossenem Handeln um die Aufrüstung
zu erhöhen ein Kriegsspiel des
US-Kongresses bei dem eine chinesische
Invasion Taiwan simuliert wurde zeigte
die Notwendigkeit die Insel bis an die
Zähne aufzurüsten die USA sollten die
Produktion von landstreckenraketen
erhöhen und die Unternehmen sollten sich
auf die wirtschaftlichen Folgen
vorbereiten aber all das der mögliche
Plan sich gegen China zu verteidigen
haben wir bereits in mehreren Videos
hier auch visualpolitik behandelt daher
lasse ich euch die Links in der
Beschreibung meine Lieben Zuschauer der
Krieg in der Ukraine hat uns zwei Dinge
gezeigt dass das Undenkbare durchaus
möglich ist und dass die Zeiten der
großen militärischen
Auseinandersetzungen leider noch lange
nicht vorbei sind das Ziel der USA ist
es Wege zu finden Taiwans Unabhängigkeit
und generell die militärische und
wirtschaftliche Überlegenheit freier
Länder gegenüber jeder Autokratie in der
Welt zu bewahren doch um dies zu
erreichen kann es unabdingbar sein
starke Unterstützung und Verbündete zu
gewinnen die Frage ist kann Taiwans de
facto Unabhängigkeit wirklich bewahrt
werden wird China bereit sein zu den
Waffen zu greifen wird es den
Vereinigten Staaten gelingen eine große
Koalition freier Länder zu bilden die
Taiwans Freiheit verteidigen hinterlasst
eure antworten bitte in den Kommentaren
und lasst uns eine Debatte eröffnen und
vergesst nicht dieses Video zu liken und
mit euren Freunden zu teilen falls ihr
es interessant fandet macht's gut und
bis zum nächsten
[Musik]
Mal